it does seem that python is quite sticky
uh is there some
uh philosophical almost thing you could
say about why python by many measures
seems to be the most popular programming
language in the world well I can tell
you things I love about it maybe that's
one way to answer the question right so
huge package ecosystem
super lightweight and easy to integrate
it has very low startup time
so it was startup time you mean learning
curve or what yeah so if you if you look
at certain other languages you say like
go and it just takes a like Java for
example it takes a long time to compile
all the things and and then the the VM
starts up and the garbage clusters kicks
in and then it revs its engines and then
it can plow through a lot of Internet
stuff or whatever right
um python is like scripting like it's it
just goes right python has very low
compile time like so you're not sitting
there waiting python integrates into
notebooks in a very elegant way that
makes exploration super interactive and
it's awesome right python is also um
it's like almost the glue of computing
because it has such a simple object
representation a lot of things plug into
it that Dynamic meta programming thing
we were talking about also enables
really expressive and beautiful apis
right so there's lots of reasons that
you can look at
technical things that python has done
and say like okay well this is actually
a pretty amazing thing and any one of
those you can neglect people all just
talk about indentation and ignore like
the fundamental things but then you also
look at the community side right so
python owns machine learning
machine learning is pretty big yeah and
it's growing and it's growing right and
it's growing in importance right and so
and there's a reputation of prestige to
machine learning to where like if you're
a new programmer you're thinking about
like which programming language do I use
well I should probably care about
machine learning therefore let me try
Python and what kind of builds and
builds it builds and even go go back
before that like my kids Learn Python
probably not because I'm telling them to
Learn Python but because were they
replying against you or what no no well
they also learn scratch right and things
like this too but it's because python is
taught everywhere right because it's
easy to learn right because it's
pervasive right and there's actually my
day we learned Java and C plus plus yeah
well uphill both directions but yes I
guess python is the main language of
teaching software engineering schools
now yeah well and if you look at if you
look at this there's these growth Cycles
right if you look at what causes things
to become popular and then gain in
popularity there's reinforcing feedback
loops and things like this and I think
python has done again the whole
Community has done a really good job of
building those growth loops and help
Propel the ecosystem and I think that
again you look at what you can get done
with just a few lines of code it's
amazing